depuis plus d'un mois les rues de moscou
sont comme dans beaucoup de capital bien
vide
les moscovites doit vivre avec les
mesures de confinement instaurée par le
gouvernement dans cette mégalopole qui
représente le principal foyer du pays
pourtant le maire de la ville estime que
les mesures sanitaires commencent à
porter leurs fruits
un collègue chers collègues grâce aux
mesures deux mois finement prise à
moscou le nombre de passagers dans les
transports publics a fortement diminué
il y a cinq fois moins de personnes tous
les transports publics continuent de
fonctionner selon leur horaire habituel
pour ne pas créer en afflux de passagers
et pour qu'ils se sentent à l'aise dans
un environnement spacieux il est bien
sûr très important de prévoir la
désinfection d'être à des stations et
des escaliers mécaniques
c'était un travail énorme que les
services de transport public effectué
tous les jours et la santé des
moscovites des ports grande partie de la
manière dont son travail est et sera
menée selon les chiffres officiels 60
2658 personnes seraient actuellement
contaminées à moscou d'après le maire de
la capitale la ville n'auraient pas
encore atteint son pic épidémique
la russie qui met aussi un point
d'honneur à prendre soin de son
personnel soignant beaucoup sont nourris
et logés gratuitement dans les hôtels de
moscou
une manière aussi d'isoler le corps
médical dans ce contexte de pandémie
reto steinmann
on nous offre le transfert on nous
nourrit donc nos contacts avec les
autres personnes sont limités car on
travaille dans la zone rouge et malgré
toutes les mesures prises il reste un
risque pour le reste de la population
pour limiter cela nos chefs et les
responsables de cet hôtel ont trouvé un
accord
au cas où ce temps là chez clinique est
utilisé mon carton doré les cils et
parmi les personnes attendent du
coronavirus le premier ministre russe
michail michou steen et le ministre de
la construction tous deux ont été placés
en isolement
de son côté vladimir poutine multiplie
les interventions à la télévision depuis
plus d'un mois le président russe a
comme beaucoup de ses concitoyens opté
pour le télétravail